[Musique]
les allocations familiales
une prestation sociale distribué à
toutes les familles françaises
un principe d'universalité mise en place
dès 1932 et qui a plusieurs fois été
remise en cause
à l'origine les allocations familiales
sont versées à tous les parents sans
conditions de ressources à partir du
deuxième enfant
mais dès les années 90 face au déficit
croissant de la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement cherche à faire des
économies
en 1995 le premier ministre alain juppé
envisagent une modulation et une
imposition des allocations familiales
d'après le premier ministre cette
fiscalisation permettrait de mieux
redistribuer l'argent de la famille une
proposition à laquelle les syndicats ne
croyait pas au bout du compte nous
constaterons que cette idée était une
fausse bonne idée
donc elle sera je pense finalement
rangée magasin d'accessoires qui n'ont
pas servi
l'idée d'une fiscalisation des
allocations familiales sera bel et bien
rangé et abandonnée par le gouvernement
deux ans plus tard nouveau premier
ministre du gauche cette fois et
nouvelle tentative de modification des
allocs lionel jospin propose un
plafonnement les foyers qui perçoivent
plus de 25000 francs nets par mois
n'auront plus droit ces allocations
je pense que c'est une décision juste
comprise par la plus grande partie de
l'opinion mais l'autre partie de
l'opinion était plutôt bien en colère
ils sont 400 environ
sans oublier leurs enfants qu'ils ont
pris soin de mettre en avant une
manifestation convoquée par deux
associations de familles proches de
l'opposition
premier mouvement d'humeur contre le
projet de réforme des allocations
familiales après plusieurs mois de
débats le principe d'universalité des
allocations familiales sera finalement
conservée jusqu'en 2014
terminées les allocations familiales
versées chaque mois sans condition de
ressources
un amendement à l'initiative des députés
socialistes est adopté toujours dans un
souci d'économie les allocations
familiales sont désormais divisés par
deux pour les parents gagnons plus de
6000 euros par mois et par quatre pour
ceux gagnant plus de 8000 euros
plus de 500 mille familles sont
concernées par cette mesure
c'est la fin du principe d'universalité
aujourd'hui les enfants de la république
ne sont plus considérés de la même façon
il ya des enfants de riches et des
enfants de pauvres en 2017 le ministre
de l'économie bruno le maire allait
encore plus loin il envisageait de
supprimer les allocations familiales
pour les parents touchant plus de 6000
euros par mois
[Musique]